When I'm in the Intensive Care Unit, I'm in charge of the team of nurses and doctors...
...who look after the sick children here.
In an average year, we look after something like 1,400 children...
...from tiny, tiny babies to teenagers.
Most days, we have 17, 18 or 19 children here...
...who are on breathing machines, who have had cardiac operations,...
...who have had accidents, who have got illnesses that they have got infections.
So every day, we are busy looking after the children in the intensive care unit.
This is Jovie.
Jovie is two and a half months old, and Jovie's been born with a problem,...
...which means that when she falls asleep, she doesn't breathe.
But it's obviously a very serious condition...
...because without a breathing machine, she'd die.
Jovie is small and sometimes she actually forgets to breathe when she is awake as well.
So Jovie is on the breathing machine day and night at the moment.
We're hoping that as she gets bigger,...
...she'll be able to come off the breathing machine during the day,...
...but for the rest of Jovie's life, she'll actually be on the breathing machine...
...when she's asleep.